. Der Podcast ist mit Flurzüten und der Stiftung. Hey, hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast. Vielen Dank an Finn mit dem Intro namens namenlos unbenannt. Vielen Dank fürs Intro, Finn. Fins mag ich ganz gern. Ja? Ja, ich kenne ein paar Fins, alle nett. Ich finde einselbig sowieso die beste Art von Namen, das einfach knackig, kurz,, Finn, Tim. Ray. Ja, zum Beispiel. Ray Romano, Ray aus Star Wars sind alle cool. Ray, der blinde Typ, alle gut. Ja, alle super. Alle toll. Wie hieß der Nummer? Ray? Mir fällt es nicht ein, leider. Parker? Nein. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Ray Charles. Ray, ja, ja. Boah, das ist zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte des Podcasts, dass, wenn man den Satz sagt, fällt mir jetzt nicht ein, dass er doch einigermaßen schnell wieder einfällt. Ja, du musst nämlich nur zwei Liter Schweiss schwitzen in diesen drei Sekunden. Das hat gereicht, dass er im Körper das rausgezogen hat. Ich glaube, dass der Satz, fällt mir gerade nicht ein, aktiv blockiert, dass es einem noch einfällt. Nein, das ist das genau der Gegenteil. Nee, ich glaube nicht. Der lockert. Du gestehst dir einen, ist es ja so wie... Du gestehst dir die Niederlage ein. Ich muss dir immer die Grundlage erklären. Wie er, na, wie heißt er? Der Typ von Madman. Bender. Don Draper. Don Draper. Don Draper, das fällt mir nie ein. Das ist sehr lustig. Und deswegen fiel es mir gerade ein, weil ich neulich wieder drauf gekommen bin. Aber es fiel mir so für einen Monat lang nicht ein. Und ich bin dann immer sehr nervös und ich will es dann immer googeln, aber ich habe gesagt, nee, das tust du dir jetzt nicht an. Ich bin einen Monat lang nicht auf Don Draper gekommen, wirklich. Aber jetzt neulich Don, Don und deswegen. Don Draper hat den kreativen Prozess beschrieben und hat gesagt, Kreativsein besteht zu 50 Prozent daraus, ein weißes Blatt anzustarren, dann aufzugeben, irgendwas anderes zu machen. Und während man was anderes macht, dann setzt sich der Gedanke auf dich wie ein Schmetterling auf deine Hand. Wenn du ihn nicht versuchst zu fangen, klingt im Englischen auch cooler. Aber in dem Moment, in dem du es nicht mehr versuchst, kommt der Gedanke zu dir. Und so ist es auch. In dem Moment, in dem du sagst, mir fällt es eh nicht ein, ah, dann kommt er und sagt Ich kann gerade nicht, ich bin auf Toilette. Herein. Don Draper. Okay. Dann kommt er rein, wenn du ihn am wenigsten erwartest, wenn du gerade nicht kannst, verstehst du? Wenn ich gerade nicht kann, kommt Don Draper rein, wenn ich gerade gar nicht kann. Nee, jemand anders kommt rein und sagt den Namen. Ach so, sagt den Namen, wer kommt dann rein? Naja, dein Gedächtnis. In dieser Metapher. Mein Gott, wir haben jetzt schon fünf Filmdeals abgeschossen. Objects 4D, Parkbenches 5D und jetzt kommt noch Metaphors 6D. Metaphors 8D. 8 fucking D, take this man. Ja, Don Draper. Ich finde, ich dachte gerade, das Zitat ist besser. Aber dann wurde es schlechter. Ich schäme mich. Während du auf ein leeres Blatt starrst und es nicht schaffst, deine Aufgabe zu legen, eine kreative Aufgabe, machst du etwas anderes. Und das ist aber das, was du dann machst, das ist das. Ach so, ich glaube, er trinkt Alkohol oder so. Ach so, ja. Und dann kommt es. Vielleicht auch wegen des Alkohols, man weiß es nicht genau. Es ist ganz klar, ich habe viel geskippt auch, ich skipp viel bei Serien und reinge das. Aber jetzt bist du ja auch kreativ tätig, also mal mehr, mal weniger, würdest du behaupten, dass es zutrifft, oder bist du der Meinung, fliegen dir die Dinge zu wie ein Schmetterling, der sich auf dein Haupt setzt? Nee, bei mir ist es auch schon oft so, dass ich oft weiss, dass es gar keinen Sinn hat, mich mit Sachen aktiv zu beschäftigen, sondern ich habe das Dokument offen auf meinem Laptop, ist offen, weiss, offen. Was für ein Dokument? Textdatei.txt, ganz Textedit, ich bin ganz basic Textedit, nicht wie du fancy Pages oder sowas. Gar nicht Pages, ich bin auch Textedit. Schön Textedit die ganze Zeit, ganz, ganz kleine Schrift, ganz winzig klein. Also nochmal Standardeinstellung und dann nochmal gut zwei Stufen raus, so winzig wie es geht. Warum, damit niemand der neben der Bahn seine Ideen klauen kann? Das auch und damit es möglichst unwichtig aussieht, so das ist so, ja da steht halt irgendwas so. Und das ist, das ist die Sankgeschwette. Ichpeichert in meinem Kopf, niemals kleine Dinge übersehen. Ja? Ja, weil das sind so diese Packungsbeilagen oder AGB-Texte. Ja, und du liest AGB-Texte oder was. Nein, aber sollte man lesen, ist einmal angerichtet worden. Na gut. Ja, aber sollen heißt nicht sein. Dürfen, können. Steffen, äh, Carsten, sorry. Donald, Donald, Draper. Donald. Und dann ist, der Teil ist offen,per und dann ist der Teil ist offen das ist wichtig der Teil ist offen und dann aber laufe ich durch die Wohnung irgendwie ich habe so einen grünen Stoffball den kicke ich dann warum ist die Farbe relevant jetzt will ich sorry aber gut naja ich bin halt nicht so der Fussballfreak und mir ist schon klar dass Fussball in der Regel nicht grün sind weil grün die denkbar schlechteste Farbe ist für einen auf dem Rasen schlechteste Farbe ist für einen Kugel im weitesten Sinne für Rasensport. Deswegen dachte ich, für die Freaks da draußen, die können das mitnehmen. Aber so kicke ich den Ball durch die Gegend und mache irgendwelche Sachen. Ja, weg von diesem Drecksball, zurück zur Scheissgeschichte. So, nee, weißt du, ich habe keine Geduld mehr. Wenn ich was anderes mache, gut, erzähl du was. Und dann wenn ich was anderes mache, oder vor allem auch, wenn ich im Bett liege nachts, dann kommt mir irgendeine Idee, dann wetz ich schnell. Oh Gott, das kommt jetzt, ja, dann wetz ich schnell zum Nachtschneider auf. Jetzt kommt die Idee, das ist der most pretentious Satz aller Zeiten immer. Nein, nein, nein. Ich finde es immer so lustig, wie Kreativ sein, und da fällt mir nach, deswegen liegt immer ein Notizzettel und ein Stift.
Bullshit!
Das ist ja nicht, aber nee, Laptop ist dann offen und dann schreibe ich das nieder.
Laptop ist offen und das weisse Licht scheint durch dein Zimmer.
Mein Problem ist, ich mache mir oft Notizen, die ich im Nachhinein nicht mehr entziffern kann.
Und da kann ich dir ja mal vielleicht tatsächlich, ich habe die hier direkt da, können wir mal schauen, kann ich dir mal vorlesen, vielleicht machen wir das so folgendermaßen, ich sage meine Notiz und du entwickelst die weiter zu einer brauchbaren Idee. Okay, Idee eins, der Mond hinter der Schattenwand. Also wahrscheinlich, bei dir ist ja immer entweder Sketch-Idee oder App-Idee.
Das sind die zwei Ideen.
Das ist natürlich, was ist das, Sketch?
So was hat der Mond zu sagen, hinter der Schattenwand.
Ja, so eine Krawall-Talkshow.
Eine Krawall-Talkshow, er will nicht erkannt werden, lässt sich aber gehörig über die Sonne aus,
weil die ja doch auch als Himmelskörper ein bisschen wichtiger empfunden wird als jetzt der Mond. Aber dann sagt er sowas wie, ja, bei Eb und Flut vergisst man völlig, wie wichtig es ist und auch gerade für die Wattwanderungswirtschaft, die Www, Wattwürmer, aber auch die Eb und Flut sind ja auch wichtig. Gezeitenkraftwerke. Gezeitenkraftwerke. Wird ja mittlerweile fast 0,01 Prozent.
Also Stroms.
Macht einen ganz großen Anteil aus.
Hält aber auch die Erde, sagen wir mal, im Gleichgewicht und deswegen ist das Wetter einigermaßen stabil.
Aber er möchte nicht erkannt werden.
Er ist ein riesiger Himmelskörper im Studio.
Ein sehr grosser, vernarbter Himmelskörper, der nicht erkannt wird.
Markante Form, markante Form.
Er möchte nicht erkannt werden.
Okay, ist doch eine gute Idee, oder?
Nein. Okay. Achtung. Es gibt schon lange kein gutes Moos mehr. So. Das ist mir auch schon aufgefallen. Ist relatable. Ist the most relatable thing I've ever heard, weil wenn man durch Wälder... Wie das schon mal gesagt. Ja, und man erinnert sich auch noch so an Spongebob-Folgen, wo er die grosse Grabe Pizza isst. Die Pizza für dich und mich. So, er hat Pizza ausgetragen, hat nicht nach Hause gefunden, zurück nach Bikini Bottom, ist dem Moos nachgegangen. Jeder von uns weiss, Moos wächst in Richtung oder und oder in die andere, in gegensätzliche Richtung
zur Zivilisation.
Wir müssen in Richtung
Moos oder und oder in die andere Richtung gehen.
Ja, aber jetzt sag mir doch mal du, wann hast du das
letzte Mal so richtig gutes Moos gesehen?
Und fällt auf, ist kein,
danach kann man sich nicht mehr richten. Nach dem Mond kann man sich
vielleicht noch richten, nach Moos nicht.
Es gibt keinen guten Moos und Mond mehr.
Bist du bei M, O angekommen eigentlich gerade in den Notizen, oder wo bist du gelandet? Achtung! Morning Show mit L. Rom Hubbard. Weißt du, wie ich mir gerade vorkomme, bei diesem, kennst du Comedy on a Net? Stand-Up-Comedy on a Net? Ja. Was ein sehr schönes Format ist, auf YouTube können wir das gucken. Und ich war letztes Jahr auch in Berlin bei einer Show Comedy without a Net, wo immer dem Publikum und dem Comedian ein Schlagwort gezeigt wird, zum Beispiel sowas, Alrom Harbrandt. Gott, wobei das wirklich für so einen... Es ist bitter, es ist wirklich bitter. Es ist nicht nur Comedy without a net, es ist Comedy with poison arrows shooting at you without a net.
Das ist erst mal 20 Minuten konzentrierte Stille.
Genau.
Wo der Komöden erst mal wirklich in sich gehen muss, reibt seinen Stirn.
Stirn, Nasen, Rücken wird massiert, bis es nicht mehr geht.
Aber kann man sich vorstellen, Morning Show mit Al Ron Hubbard?
Das ist der Bruder von Al Ron Hubbard, oder was? Den Erfinder von Scientology. Ja. Gut. Es wird auch sehr viel Wissen vorausgesetzt. Aber auch Al-Rom, also das Al bleibt gleich und Hubbard bleibt gleich, nur das Ron, das ist der Zweitname. Also dein Kind heißt es genauso wie das Erste und nur im Zweitnamen ändert es sich. Ich habe auch eine gute Idee, aber es ist schwierig, aber einen habe ich noch, Achtung. Wie ging CD-Rom? Ui, jetzt habe ich alles gedöscht. Nein, wirklich? Ne, habe ich nicht. Oh, da war ich kurz nervös. Und dann auch Achtung. Weil es könnten tolle Ideen wie Al Rom Hubbard verloren gehen. Da war ich kurz ernsthaft Concern. Das glaubt ihr nicht. Das war die Fallhöhe aus-Rom-Havard und dem Gesicht, was du gerade gemacht hast, als du kurz dachtest, du hättest alle gelöscht, gar nicht angemessen. Eigentlich hätte ich sagen müssen, die sind alle weg. Achtung, passt ganz gut hier zu uns, und zwar die Notiz, Rollschuhe der Karibik, etc, etc, etc, etc. etc. etc. etc. Aber fällt auf, dass die Städtchen und Örtlichkeiten, wo man am liebsten Rollschuh fahren würde, auch am wenigsten dafür geeignet sind durch Sand etc. pp. pp. etc. Also du meinst den klassischen L.A. Strand, wo die Inlineskater rumfahren,
man will ja GTA Vice City
nachempfunden an den Promenaden
Miamis, Floridas
oder halt
Miamis Langfahren mit seinen Rollschuhchen
und kann es nicht
aufgrund von Sand.
Bist du nicht schon mal Rollschuhe gefahren? Ich rede nicht von Landskates.
Ich weiß, dass du, das ist deine große
Ich als Style Express-Fan der ersten Stunde, als die Originalsongs noch gesungen wurden und Papa Papa war und ich Mama. Da, dabei wusste ich schon, dass es Rollschuh... Ganz kritische Stimmung gerade noch. Nee, ich finde es toll, dass Mama ist. Ich habe nicht den Hauer, eine Ahnung, wovon du redest, aber ich merke, die Stimmung ist eiskalt geworden plötzlich. Ne, die haben halt Songs geändert, das nervt mich halt, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Wobei es war wirklich eine ganz, also rückblickend, wir haben ja auch über die Stimmung des Biest gesprochen, wo du in unserer beliebten Rubrik Florentin-Zellig-Klassiker Filme, wir können ja mal Stefan-Zellig-Musicals machen, das ist meine Kindertisch-Rubrik. Ich glaube, das wird der nächste grosse Shitstorm. Das wird der nächste grosse Hit, glaube ich, weil die Botschaft von Strada Express, gut, wenn es ihn denn gibt, weil es ja dann doch im Kern einfach um fucking Züge geht, die einfach Typen in Rollschuhen sind, ist schon ziemlich fragwürdig, weil es gibt den Song, ich bin nicht G-E-K-O-P-P-E-L-T, ich bin nicht gekuppelt.
Die Frauen können nur von A nach B kommen, wenn sie einen Mann hinten dran hängen.
Die Frauen sind die Waggons, die Männer in Style Express sind die Lokomotiven.
Und heißt der Song so, oder hast du das jetzt gerade so gesagt, damit Kinder nicht wissen, was gemeint ist? Damit Kinder nicht wissen, worüber wir hier reden. Nee, sie singt bin nicht G-E-K-U-P-P-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E-L-T-E, er ist nur ein B-A-E-S-T-A-R-D.
Aber tatsächlich auch nicht der beste Song, finde ich auch ganz ehrlich, aber der zeigt halt auch ein bisschen das Problem von Sutter Express damals.
Deswegen bin ich mittlerweile echt ganz froh, dass es Mama ist und nicht Papa, weil da ist ganz was falsch gelaufen.
Die ganzen Girls waren halt nur Waggons, die immer, und dann gab es noch den hoten Erstklasse-Waggon, also alles ein bisschen fragwürdig, gendermässig, und deswegen hat das wahrscheinlich da auch ein bisschen einer Erneuerung bedarf, aber trotzdem kein zeitgemässiges Musical. Ja. Wir treten ja übrigens auf bald. Tatsächlich treten wir da auf. Im Side Express Arena. Ja, oder? Mittlerweile haben die viele Songs geändert, die ich ja auch nicht mehr so kenne. Aber da steht schon noch die Deko rum, oder? Also ich werde mir da was umschneiden. Wie Deko? Ich werde mir da schön die Rollschuhe umschneiden. Ich will aber auch für den Auftritt mit Rollschuhen rumfahren. Es gibt noch viele Karten. Holt sie euch. Es gibt viel zu viele Karten noch. Also es gibt mehr Karten, als wir ursprünglich angefangen haben. Ganz merkwürdiges passiert, aber tatsächlich kamen Leute und haben noch ein paar Stühle reingestellt und wir haben jetzt mehr Karten, als wir eigentlich ursprünglich hatten. Also wir können uns gut verstehen, dass es jetzt gerade in diesen Zeiten normal ist, dass man vielleicht nicht so sehr im Voraus Veranstaltungen plant. Wir nehmen das nicht persönlich, meint Stefan. Wir nehmen das nicht persönlich. Wir würden uns aber trotzdem freuen. Ja, wir würden uns halt, also wie gesagt, wir sind nicht sauer oder so, aber... Das perfekte Weihnachtsgeschenk. Das ist halt schon auch echt ein gutes Weihnachtsgeschenk. Genau wie unsere Socken. Ja, stimmt. Und unser Rucksack. Und unser Bildschirmfone. Der aussieht wie ein kleiner Florentin, der an ihm dranhängt. Der vorne an einem dranhängt, wie so ein kleines Kind, aber es ist ein Rucksack. Es ist ein Rucksack, einlicher Rucksack. Keine schlechte Idee. Ich weiß nicht. Es gibt bei der Star Wars Celebration, läuft dieser Zweite mit diesem Yoda-Rucksack rum, der aussieht wie Luke, der mit Yoda trainiert,
der hängt ja hinten an ihn dran.
Aber kann man da nicht so ein Baby-Netz vorne am Bauch haben mit Baby-Yoda?
Baby-Yoda, ja.
Dass hinten der grosse Yoda ist und vorne Baby-Yoda.
Vorne klein, überall Yodas, am Koppersen-Yoda.
Schlägt am Yoda-Eis, im Stiel, einfach so, ich mag halt Yoda.
Ich mag Yodas.
Ich Yodas mag halt.
Schade, dass es diese Messen dieses Jahr nicht gab. Wir haben ja wirklich was verpasst. Oh mein Gott. Ach, es war schon schön. Ich war ja tatsächlich als, merkwürdig, man ist als Kind von Dingen Fan, was man sich a nicht erklären kann und b irgendwann auch nicht mehr ist. Anscheinend war ich als Kind riesen Asterix und Obedix Fan. Ich erinnere mich nämlich, dass wir mal auf so einer Messe waren, auf der Asterix und Obelix Messe, wo es auch Wildschwein zu essen gab. Und ich kann nicht erinnern. Und Hinkelsteine zu tragen. Hinkelsteine hatte man zu tragen. Und man merkt bei beiden Dingen, Wildschweine isst man aus gutem Grund nicht mehr und Hinkelsteine trägt man auch aus gutem Gründen nicht mehr. Richtig. Und man konnte auch feststellen, warum. Das ist sauschwer, die Dinger sind verdammt schwer. Und danach gehen alle von dieser Messe herunter und sind keine Fans mehr. Ich erinnere mich noch an das Wildschein. Ich glaube, das schmeckt ja ganz gut. Ja, das Wildschein. So mit Pfeffer und Salz, so ein bisschen auf so ein Brötchen. Hat Geschmächt. Das einzige, woran ich mich erinnere. Aber anscheinend war ich mal Riesen-Asterix und Oberdichts-Fan, mittlerweile gar nicht mehr. Aber als Elternteil auch furchtbar, also furchtbar und gut zu wissen, weil es ist furchtbar zum einen, weil man denkt, oh, warum man jetzt Asterix und Obelix? Ich bin von den acht Franchises ein, wo mein Kind lieber Fan sein sollte. Aber du zwängst es deinem Kind doch auf, oder? Du zwängst deinem Kind doch die Hobbys auf. Wurden dir Asterix und Obelix aufgezwängt? Also ich habe mich nicht dafür entschieden. Also ich glaube nicht, dass es mir aufgezwängt wird. Deine Eltern haben sich entschieden, dich zum AsterixSobox-Fan zu machen. Ja, also warum denn nicht? Also es gibt schlimmere Fansachen. Ja, ja, das stimmt. Aber ich habe jetzt von einer sehr guten Freundin, der Neffe, der kleine Neffe, der ist gerade in so einer Phase, wo ich dann damals auch eher Dino-Fan war oder generell Kinder, so Lego-Star-Wars-Dinos-Fan, das Fan von Hühnern. Er liebt Hühner, weil irgendwie seine Oma so einen Hühnerstall hat und der ist aber der größte Hühner-Fan. Und während sein Bruder halt die ganze Zeit Dinos sammelt von Schleich, will der halt die Schleich huhnen. Aber ist das nicht sehr konsequent, dass der Evolutionär den nächsten Schritt geht? Ja, geht. T, fällt mir gerade auf, ja, den nächsten Schritt. Eigentlich ist er sehr modern in seiner Hobby. Eigentlich im Prinzip sehr modern, aber jetzt, aber man erwischt sich, ich ja selber als unbeteiligte dritte Person, denke mir so, oh Gott, ey. Und dann auch die Freundin, die dann immer irgendwie zu Weihnachten halt diese Schleichgeschenke besorgen muss, dann immer diese, ich muss wieder einen Schleichhuhn. Und jedes Mal denke ich, ich denke, oh Gott, was ist mit dem Jungen los? Jetzt redet man immer diese Huhnphase auf. Was hört denn die auf? Und jetzt geht die auch schon irgendwie so drei Monate, wo man denkt, boah, wirklich eine Huhnphase? Ja, da braucht eine Intervention, aber jetzt hat er sich interessiert für Schlagzeug. Und man denkt so, und ich war wirklich, ich als aussenstehende unbeteiligte Person dachte mir schon so, holy fuck, wäre ich als Elternteil leichter. Das ist diese Huhnphase vorbei. Aber ist Schlagzeug nicht das fucking Nervigste, was sein Kind macht? Ja, aber es ist halt fucking, yes! Badass, es ist Rock'n'Roll, Rock'n'Roll, da strinke ich sowohl den Zeigefinger als auch den Kleinfinger weit in die Höhe. Genau, das ist das beschreiben, was Stefan macht. Stefan nutzt jetzt seine Hand dazu, um bildlich einen Schafskopf, Stierkopf zu bemen. Ist es nicht so der Satansbock, der Widder oder so? Keine Ahnung, ist ja auch egal. Ja, das kannst du in diesem Podcast nicht sagen. Wenn du den Satz sagst, ist ja auch egal, tötest du. Ist ja egal. Du reisst uns gerade den Boden und den Füssen weg.
Du steilest am Ast, ob du hier sitzt.
Aber ich dachte ehrlich gesagt, es geht in eine andere Richtung, weil ich als Elternteil bei einem Schlagzeuginteresse sagen würde, oh, was ist Bock, bock, bock, bock, bock, was ist das denn? Willst du nicht zurück zu deinen Hüten? Boak, boak, boak, boak, boak, boak, boak, boak.
Weil auf Schlagzeug hatte ich überhaupt keinen Bock, dass das Kind die ganze Zeit Schlagzeug macht.
Ich hatte ja schon, ich hatte über mir, bei meiner alten Kölner Wohnung, wohnte über mir wahrscheinlich unter Musikern, Musiker sind immer nervig, aber unter Musikern das angenehmste, was man haben kann, ein Jazz-Bassist, der Kontrabass gespielt hat. Dann hast du ja den ganzen Tag so.
Kann man gut ausblenden auch im Kopf.
Es ist wie ein Soundtrack, es ist wie so ein Sitcom-Soundtrack, du machst die Tür auf und dann so. Du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du, du-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum Wie bei King of Queens, wenn das Haus zu sehen war, dann kam immer dieser Gitarren-Sound. Ich dachte mir, wie geil das wäre, wenn er irgendwann sieht, dann schwenkt die Kamera so leicht nach rechts. Und immer wenn man auf der Strasse ist, auf dieses Haus guckt, sitzt halt einfach so ein Gitarrenspieler, dieses Spiel. Stimmt, in der letzten Staffel, letzte Folge. Letzte Folge ist dann dieser Gitarrist einfach mal da. Steht auf und geht. Und geht einfach vor so einen Zug. Setzt dich mit seiner Gitarre auf die Gleise. Letzte Staffeln sind oft weird, glaube ich. Ich meine, da kannst du wahrscheinlich mehr dazu sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ob man oft, es gibt wahrscheinlich zwei Situationen. Man schreibt die letzte Staffel und weiss, dass es die letzte Staffel ist, und man weiss es nicht. Ich glaube, wenn man weiss, dass es die letzte Staffel ist, macht man so eine geheime Schublade auf, so von den ganzen Ideen, die man in der ganzen Zeit sammelt. Ja, wie bei Gute Arbeit. Weil bei Gute Arbeit wussten wir ja schon ganz früh, dass es vorbei ist. Und dann haben wir angefangen, seitdem es klar war, schon so ein paar Hints zu setzen along the way. Müssten wir nochmal gucken, wenn dann das ganze Gute Arbeitwerk, das gesammelte Werk, was ich gerne eigentlich nochmal irgendwann als Blu-Ray-Box rausholen. Eigentlich noch mal erschienen, also als zwölfbändiges Sammelband von Glad Cotter irgendwie,
noch mal so wirklich, dass man sich auch sonst ins Regal stellen kann.
Das finde ich auch schön, ja.
Ja, genau wo so eine Karte noch drauf ist, so eine Karte von Köln.
Weil ich fand es immer schön, als bei GTA zum Beispiel, da war immer noch so eine Karte von dem Stadt.
Ah ja, das fand ich immer schön einfach.
Ja.
So ich kann einfach, ohne dass es jetzt ein Bewandwandnis hätte bei uns, einfach auch trotzdem reinballern. Ich habe mir ein Simpsons-Poster bestellt. Jetzt? Ja, ja. Ich liebe Simpsons. Und ich habe ein Simpsons-Poster bestellt. Ja, ja, kannst ja ohne Poster lieben. Nee, ich bin großer Fan. Du musst ja nicht unbedingt diese Hühner dir kaufen. Du kannst ja Hühner im Stillen lieben. Nee, ich finde, Liebe ist laut. Liebe muss laut sein. Und ich habe mir Simpsons-Poster bestellt, und das ist ja echt gelb, ich sage mal tricky, weil im Internet manche Dinge sieht man und man hat die Masse sofort klar. Also du siehst irgendwie eine Kaffeemaschine auf Amazon. Ich nicht, ich habe ein Bild gekauft, das ist acht mal neun Meter groß, aber ich sage mir, passt das in mein Auto? Klar. Ja, und tatsächlich ist mir jetzt der Anti-Stefan passiert, die da so ein Poster bestellt. Und wenn man ein Poster bestellt, dann hat es die klassische Postergrösse. Nein, DIN A5. 50 mal 70, okay. DIN A5, wirklich, was man so... Die Hälfte von A4, ne? Er hilft dir von der A4, so die Hengsten an die Wand und es sieht halt nichts aus. Keine Wand ist darauf ausgelegt, ein Diener fünf grosses Poster zu tragen. Es sieht immer zu klein aus, es sieht immer lächerlich aus. Aber du kannst dich auch nicht beschweren, weil das wäre wahrscheinlich irgendwo da gestanden. Aber wenn es da heiß... Nee, ich finde, wenn ein Diener Poster steht, finde ich, kann man es gut zurückschicken. Willst du es mal ausmachen oder willst du es anlassen? Da ist genug Zeit vergangen zwischen den beiden dass man vielleicht auch mal ausmachen könnte. Ist es jetzt schon so weit in dem Podcast, dass wir unsere Handys anlassen und zwischendurch auch mal einfach telefonieren und rausgehen oder so? Aber ich finde, wenn da Plakat steht, dann wurde es dahinter nicht geführt. Ich weiß nicht, ob Plakate da steht oder Poster oder ob das noch was anderes ist. Ja, weil ich finde, A5 ist ja, was ist A5? A5 ist gar nichts. Kuvert-Größe. Kuvert, das ist ein Notizblock, das ist gar nichts. Ich habe aber auch mal einen Poster bestellt von etwas und dann kam das Poster nicht nur sehr klein an, sondern auch aus Metall. Das war so ein Blechschild. Blechschild. Komplett aus dem Nichts, komplett aus der Seite. Man bekommt irgendwie, das ist ja auch merkwürdig, das ist ja oft so, du kriegst ja manchmal aufregende Post. Manchmal hat man aufregende Post im Briefkasten, wo man sagt so, uh, was ist das? Und so ein Diener-Vier-grosses Blech eingepackt ist erst mal schon so ein, hm, weil du spürst es, du kannst es nicht biegen, es ist hart, es hat eine gewisse Schwere. Kam auch viel zu spät, das sind immer so die, die, wo gehörig was falsch gelaufen ist, die kommen auch immer viel zu spät, dass man aber auch was ganz Geiles vergessen hat, was man da bestellt hat. Ja. Und bei mir kommt auch häufig manchmal was an, wo man denkt, was das sind jetzt nochmal genau. Ich liebe das aber, das sind die besten. Weil vor allem, es ist ja wirklich so, du bestellst was und das soll meinetwegen in zwei Tagen kommen. Und wenn es in drei Tagen kommt, bist du schon ein bisschen wütend. Wenn es in vier Tagen kommt, bist du wütend. Aber wenn es in neunzig Tagen kommt, dann bin ich auch nicht mehr wütend denn also dann habe ich überhaupt keinen ärger mehr sondern sagst du ach schön dass es doch noch muss ja einiges erlebt haben ja setz dich erst mal hin komm erst mal rein komm ich nehme dir den mantel ab setz dich kurz willst du einen kaffee wir machen das jetzt ganz entspannt so du musst jetzt auch nicht direkt an die wand also als poster sondern kommst jetzt erst mal jetzt erstmal irgendwie, legst dich mal hin. Das sind dann eigentlich die Überraschungen. Bei mir ist jetzt ein Paket beschädigt worden und das ist jetzt einfach in so einem Nirvana. Man weiß nicht genau, weil es sollte geliefert werden gestern und dann kam eine SMS, tut mir leid, ihr DAL-Paket verspätet sich, es wurde beschädigt. Und jetzt ist es irgendwo beschädigt. Ja und du hast hast nicht gefragt, ja und, kann ich es besuchen, wo ist es? Wo liegt es denn? Kann ich es besuchen kommen? Nein. Nein. Es darf noch keine... Es ist noch nicht stabil. Es ist noch unter Schock. Jetzt in dem Lagerhaus. Und dann, wo ist er, wo ist er, und da ist es Paket und da ist einfach so ein Speer, ein Versteck so quer durch. Aber wie konnte das passieren? Ja, wir wissen es nicht, er kam so rein. Er wurde so angeliefert. Ja, geht's dir gut. Und was macht man in so einer Situation? Ja, und dann so, und dann geht der Arzt, geht einem so um die Ecke mit einem. Ja, genau, und er zieht so den Vorhang zu. Nee, wahrscheinlich wäre es das Beste, wenn sie einfach... Einfach retour. Was? Aber ich ... Kann das doch nicht retours? Aber ich fühle mich ja auch schon verantwortlich. Nein, aber ich ... Trauen Sie mir in solchen Situationen. Das ist das Beste, einfach Retour. Man sollte also nicht zurückgucken und einfach es retournieren. Wir kümmern uns darum. Die Annahme verweigern. Genau, in der App einfach dann die Order aufrufen und auf das X und dann wir kümmern uns um den Rest. Verweigere hier mit die Annahme. Sie haben das Recht getan. Das ist ein Schachbrett. Ja? Ja. Du bist im Schachhype. Ich bin im Schachhype und wie man mich kennt und liebt. Du willst was Hartes haben. Ja, nee, aber wo ich für dich klischee-mäßig ich selbst bin, wieder merke ich. Phase kommt und gerade bin ich so drin in der, ich lese mich ein Phase. Aber auch nicht mehr irgendwie lustig, haha, ich spiele Online-Schach gegen Freunde. Ich bin von der Serie lässt sich streiten, Queen's Gambit, trotzdem bin ich dadurch in so einen Schachfieber gerutscht. Wie viele glaube ich gerade, Also du dürftest auch viele Leute treffen, die momentan anfangen? Voll und generell Schach erfolgt sich ja gerade grosser Beliebtheit. Bei den tollen Rocket Beans gibt es ein phantastisches Format, das glaube ich gerade nicht läuft, oder? Nee, abgeschlossen. Abgeschlossen, aber der Schachhype ist allgegenwärtig. Völlig zu Recht auch, phantastisches Spiel hat ja auch so ein bisschen den Test der Zeit überstanden, muss man sagen. Wobei es stimmt nicht, es gibt ein laufendes Format, die Lach-und-Schach-Geschichten, mit dem phantastischen Jan Gustafsson, das läuft natürlich, aber es gab auch Zugzwang, das Turnier, das es beendet. Okay, gut. Also schaut gerne doch mal rein. Schaut gerne generell mal rein. Lach-und-Schach-Geschichten. Lach-und-Schach-Geschichten. Und ja, ich habe jetzt online angefangen, gegen sehr viele Freunde zu spielen, die auch beeinflusst wurden von der Serie. Schon fantastisch. Und ich bin jetzt gerade in der Reihenleserphase, Literaturphase, mache gerade die Masterclass von Gary Kasparrow. Also ich bin ganz tief drin. Und das macht Spaß, ehrlich gesagt. Also du hakst alle Boxen der Stefan-Phase ab, du schaust die entsprechende Masterclass an, du bestellst dir irgendwas viel zu teures auf Amazon, du liest dich ein, driftest dabei ab und liest mehr über die Geschichte des Schach als über eigentlich die Schachregeln. Merke ich dann aber, dann in Krüger, dass ich jetzt gar nicht so viel weiss über Schach, wie ich immer dachte, dass ich es weiss, bin damit aber auch ganz zufrieden. Bin aber jetzt schon wieder bei dem Punkt hinaus, jetzt bin ich schon wieder sinuskurrenmäßig, jetzt auch an dem Punkt, wo ich denke, ja, ich bin der Beste, vielleicht ist er mir, ich habe es sogar bei dem Gedanken gespielt, warum denn nicht, weil viele wollen ja jetzt einen Master und so einen Scheiß noch machen, viele bei meinem Alter, Freunde machen jetzt nochmal einen Master und wollen doch nochmal den Doktor, keine Ahnung, nein, ich will den Grossmeister, ich will den Schach-Grossmeister. Bescheiden wie du bist, sagst du, nee, ich will den Grossmeister. Aber gibt es da noch eine Vorstufe oder ist man einfach nichts oder Grossmeister? Ja, man ist nichts oder Grossmeister. Oder dann gibt es auch Super-Grossmeister, die haben eine krassere Elo-Zahl. Die Elo-Zahl ist die Zahl, die entscheidet, wie gut man ist. Aber komm, hätte man da nicht so etwas Cooles ausdenken, so Erz-Grossmeister oder so. Super-Grossmeister? Ja. Ich meine, das ist so wie wenn es beim Karate gibt es ja auch irgendwie dann die verschiedenen Farben der Gürtel und am Ende schwarz. Bei Schach gibt es einfach nur schwarz-weiss. Im Prinzip ist Schach ein schwarz-weisses Spiel, ja. Konsequent muss man ihn lassen. Bis zu Ende gedacht, wirklich. Ich bin gespannt, wie lange die Phase dauert. Ich sag mal, ich setze noch nicht allzu viel Geld auf deine Schachliebe, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das schaffst mit dem Schach-Grossmeister, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Ich glaube, in zwei Wochen kommst du mit einem Saxophon um den Hals durch die Tür und dann kommt die nächste Phase wieder, die sehr laut wird. Es gibt immer die lauten und die leisen Phasen momentan, Schach nur ganz leise. Ja, aber ohne Scheiß. Schachkur? Nee, Schachkur habe ich noch nicht geholt. Ich habe hier so ein Brett und Figürchen. Ich war ja im Schachclub als Kind, tatsächlich. Ich war auch in der Schach-AG als Kind, ja. Nee, ich war im Schachclub und in der Go-AG, aber da nur ganz kurz. Und die haben sich auch so ein bisschen gehasst gegenseitig. Auf jeden Fall. Weil jeder hat Gründe, warum sein Spiel cooler ist. Go ist ja so ein bisschen nur mit den schwarzen und weißen Steinen, wo es nämlich verschiedene Figuren gibt, auf diesen großen Brettern. Was wir mal gegeneinander gespielt haben, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich noch erinnerst, nachdem diese Doku rauskam. Mit dem Go Alpha Go, genau. Da haben wir danach mal gegeneinander gespielt, auch online, auch ein spannendes, sehr umkämpftes, sehr enges Match. Auf sehr niedrigem Niveau, aber ausgeglichen. Sehr ausgeglichen, fantastisch eng, hart umkämpft, schlecht gegen schlecht und dann habe ich einen Stein gelegt und die Hälfte des Brettes war weg, also alle Steine waren weg. Werbung Wir lieben Cyberport, Cyberport ist unser Laden und wir haben heute die Ehre, euch ein ganz besonderes Produkt vorzustellen, was ihr da kaufen könnt. Ja, wir haben ja schon häufig über Laptops gesprochen, Laptops sagt man ja oft so ein bisschen nach, die haben nicht so richtig was unter der Haube, die können nicht richtig leisten, aber dieses Prachtstück, das vereint in seinem kleinen, schmächtigen Körper eine Menge Power. Denn wir haben für euch den Dell Alienware M17R3, der ist fantastisch, hat ordentlich was zu bieten, aber was ganz besonders daran ist, ist nämlich diese unglaubliche Kühlung.
Mir friert in meiner Wohnung alles weg, sag ich dir ganz ehrlich. Und ich bin nicht so pingelig, ich bin keine Frostbeule. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Aber mir friert alles zu. Der ist arschkalt. Diese Kühle bewirkt auch einiges, denn natürlich könnt ihr auch mit einer fantastischen Grafik rechnen, mit bis zu zwölffasiger Grafikspannregulierung und ein FHD-Display mit 144 Hz Bildwiederholfrequenz und neun Millisekunden Reaktionszeit. Das ist schnell. Kannst du so schnell reagieren? Neun Millisekunden ist zu schnell. Also es ist ein super schnelles Ding, wahnsinnig state of the art, eiskalt, eiskaltes Gerät und das bekommt ihr am besten bei Cyberport. Einfach bessere Technik. Einfach die richtige Technik. Einfach richtig gute Technik. Einfach die richtige Technik. Einfach Technik. Cyberport. Technik. Werbung Letzten gegen den vorletzten spielen. Die beiden spielen gegeneinander und das dann beim Fernsehen übertragen. Wirklich nicht die besten der besten, sondern einfach wirklich die beiden grottenschlechtesten, die es irgendwie geschafft haben von, ich weiß nicht, wie viele User so eine Plattform hat, zwei Millionen. Das sind wirklich die allerletzten. Ich finde auch im Profisport, auch beim Fussball oder so, hat sich ja durchgesetzt, dass man die besten Mannschaften gegeneinander antreten lässt. Ja. Aber der Spaß ist ja nicht, dass es so tolle Mannschaften sind, so Top-Athleten, der Spaß ist ja auch, wenn zwei ebenbürtige Mannschaften aufeinandertreten. Richtig. Finde ich jetzt auch nicht so schlecht, irgendwie Kassel-Brausel, VfL Kassel-Brausel gegen, weiß ich nicht, Bad Orb zu sehen, finde ich ja auch nicht so schlecht. Da ist immer, je kürzer der Name, desto kritischer die Fussballleistung. Aber so Estibat Orb gegen Castro Brauchsel finde ich jetzt nicht so schlecht. Wie so diese kruden Namen. Die letzten beiden der Skala, gibt es ja auch irgendeine Liste oder so, die letzten beiden werden dann antreten. Darum geht es ja, die aber dann ebenbürtig sind. Und das ist ja auch bestimmt ein spannendes Spiel, was dann auch so knapp 2-1 ausgeht und hart umkämpft. Oder halt so 16-16 ausgeht, weil die einfach der Torwart irgendwie Rückenschmerzen hat. Nichts hält. Und zu spät kommt, aber das ist ja auch. Steht im Stau, telefoniert, versucht übers Telefon noch zu regeln. Ja, stell du ins Tor. Geh nach links, geh nach links. Schwierig. Nee, geh nicht. Das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Eigentlich gar nicht gut, das mal umzudenken. Warum immer gut, gut, gut. Nein, auch mal schlecht, schlecht, schlecht. Nee, auch mal die beiden Langsamsten gegeneinander andrehen lassen. Einfach die rinnen lassen. Gucken, wer gewinnt. Dann kannst du dir, ist ja auch viel besser so, 100 Meter Sprint ist immer nervig. Weil zu kurz ist. Weil du hast ja einmal kurz eine TV-Störung und es ist vorbei. Wogegen wir die langsamsten laufen, kannst dir ja was zu essen holen, Flips, Packung auf, guck mal, ich habe hier diesen Trick, wenn du da die umkrempelst bei der Chipstüte, dann hält es auf und du sagst, interessiert mich nicht, lass uns doch jetzt bitte kurz einfach das angucken. Und dann ist das Leuchtenrennen noch. Ja, voll, finde ich super. Können wir gerne mal irgendwie nach vorne treiben. Ich glaube, wo ich am meisten lustig, ich habe gerade überlegt, was ist die Sportart, wo ich am liebsten den beiden schlechtesten zuschauen würde. Und ich glaube, ich bin bei Snooker. Weil da dauert so ein, wirklich von dem schlechtesten gegen den zweitschlechtesten, das dauert halt mal so sechseinhalb Stunden, bis da überhaupt jemand mal eine Kugel reingebekommen hat. Du bist da viel Frust. Man versucht sich gegenseitig zu helfen, einfach damit überhaupt was passiert. Die meisten Zuschauer sind weg. Der Schiedsrichter hat gesagt, Leute, ich bin raus. Das wird nichts mehr. Das ist eine Scheißidee, Stefan Flog. Wir sitzen und das teuer bezahlte Kameracrew-Team ist wahnsinn in Schwitzen, weil wir denken, war das vielleicht eine doofe Idee, die schlechtesten Snookerspieler antreten zu lassen. Auch die Frage, was ist da jetzt schlechteste Snookerspieler? Weil wir werden ja nicht mehr Snookerspieler. Oder nehmen wir die am schlechtesten, für die Sportart geeignetesten Menschen der Welt? Ohne Arme einfach. Nein, wir würden ja trotzdem Snookerspieler nehmen, aber halt die schlechtesten. Ist halt Paralympics neu gedacht. Also in die andere Richtung gedacht. Ja, aber das sind ja trotzdem Top-Athleten für ein Team. Das weiß ich doch. Nenn mir, Nenn nicht seine Frau umgebracht hat. Nenn mir einen Paralympics-Star. Das ist jetzt gemein. Nenn mir einen Paralympics-Star. Nee, komm. Nenn mir einen Paralympics-Star, aber es ist einer, der nicht seine Frau angemacht haben darf. Oder was seine Frau, eine Frau erschossen hat. Das ist jetzt natürlich, also klar, naja. Aber auch schwierig für einen Sport, wenn der einzige weltbekannte Sportparalympics-Star halt leider wegen des Mordfalls berühmt geworden ist.
Ich bin ja immer noch auch Riesenfan von O.J. Simpsons Twitter-Account. Es ist herrlich. Es ist wirklich, der hat ja seine Frau umgebracht und ist aber dafür nicht bestraft worden und
kam dann irgendwann wieder raus, weil er für was anderes im Gefängnis war und ist jetzt auf
Twitter und er twittert halt immer noch, der war auch eine Football-Legende und so und twittert immer nur zu Football irgendwie der grosse Spieler, der hat den guten Move gemacht, aber jeder einzelne Kommentar auf seine Posts beinhaltet in irgendeiner Weise, dass er seine Frau umgebracht hat. Nicht immer sofort ersichtlich, nicht immer sofort, aber dann doch schon. Und ich denke, der muss das auch lesen und denkt sich, jetzt reicht es auch mal so. Aber wirklich jeder bei jedem Post, egal zu welchem Thema, immer kommen die Kommentare auf. Aber das ist auf eine Art auch cool, dass er da jetzt nicht irgendwie so die Lust verliert am Twitter. Nee, also Das ist mir jetzt wert, dass ich diesen Move wieder bewerten. Ja, also der ist, was Shitstorms angeht, ein Vorbild. Also der hat sich da wirklich nicht verleihen. Ja, auch für uns ein Vorbild, so im Umgang mit Social Media. Weil ich lasse mich ja auch dann doch beeinflussen. Ich auch. Du, ich habe mich zwei Tage lang verkrochen, weil die ganze Podcast-Suche-Hörerschaft auf mich eingedroschen hat zum Thema Die Schöne und das Biest, die mir gepostet hat, hier gibt es eine Quelle, da sieht man, dass die nicht Gegenstände sein wollen und so. Nee, aber das überzeugt mich nicht. Auch damals zur zweiten Folge Filmfights bei Rocket Beans, ein Format, was Flo und Töne nicht dann damals angefangen haben zu gelauncht haben. Was du dann losgelassen hast wie eine heiße Kartoffel? Nee, ich habe einfach nicht mehr geschafft, nach Hamburg zu kommen.
Aber weißt du ja auch, muss ich mir nicht dumm rechtfertigen.
Aber ich habe wenig Angst gehabt vor der zweiten Folge damals,
weil da ein oder andere negative Kommentare waren bei der ersten Folge.
Und ich bin da so beeinflussbar und es tat mir so weh, aber ich bin nicht getraut. Ja, das fand ich auch echt scheiße, wie die Leute damit, weil da gab es dann auch Compilations von dir und sowas finde ich einfach bescheuert. Wie äl, äl Compilations. Äl Compilations und das Problem ist ja bei solchen Sachen, die Leute meinen das ja gar nicht böse. Ich finde das sehr lustig, denen ist nicht bewusst, wie sehr sie jemandem wehtun und deswegen gibt es ja so auch oft immer so, don't feed the troll, geh da gar nicht drauf ein. Aber ich finde, manchmal muss man den Leuten auch schon sagen so, hey, was du vielleicht lustig meinst, tut anderen Leuten wirklich weh. Also das ist nur, du hast das als Gag zusammengeschnitten, das ist ja auch viel Arbeit. Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob es so viel Arbeit war. Ich habe schon oft ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, auch er ist gar nicht bis zum Ende gekommen, derjenige. Ja,, die Compilation war auch irgendwie 20 Minuten kürzer als die eigentliche Folge. Das stimmt schon, da muss man nicht viel machen. Aber im Endeffekt ist den Leuten auch nicht klar, dass sowas dann auch wirklich in dem Moment auch wehtut. So jetzt im Nachhinein, so ist es wahrscheinlich anders. Ja, jeder weiß, dass es von dir ist, diese Compilation. Ach Quatsch, also das ist ja jetzt, du kannst dir den Accountnamen angucken, das weisst du ja, dass es nicht stimmt. Aber ja, naja, da muss man sich echt ein Beispiel an O.J. Simpson nehmen. Ja, absolut. Also, weil der geht da mit einem oder anders um. Der hört mich wirklich gut um. Der schlägt auch nicht zurück, sondern der weiß einfach, wo er steht. Ja, der kennt seinen Platz, also der weiß, wo er hingehört, der kennt seine Stärken und seine Schwächen. Und das für uns alle ist O.J. Simpson dann Vorbild. Und ich will auch, dass die Folge so heißt. Ich glaube, wir haben sogar schon eine Folge, die so heißt. O.J. Simpson ist ein Vorbild? Nee, nicht O.J. Simpson ist unser Vorbild. Nein, das noch nicht. Aber gut. Das ist noch... Wir wollen so sein wie O.J. Simpson. Aber O.J. Simpson ist unsere Vorbild. Eins bis drei, die Frauen unvergessen. Vielleicht können wir ihn ja einen Tages als Gast haben. Lebt der noch? Ich dachte, der wäre tot eigentlich. Ich dachte, der wäre mausetot. Der lebt noch. Aber du hast jetzt so einen Typen, wo jeder weiss, dass er diesen Mord begangen hat, aber er wurde halt vom Gericht freigesprochen und du kannst nicht zweimal für dieselbe Tat. Und er steht auf eine Art auch zwischen einem, wenn man mit ihm spricht. Es liegt in der Luft auch schon so. Es ist natürlich, der Kirschkuchen war hervorragend, ein absoluter Gaubenschmaus, aber man kommt halt nicht umhin, sich auch gewahr zu werden, dass der halt jemand umgebracht hat. Glaubst du, das Wort Mausetot fiel schon mal auf einer Beerdigung?
Vielleicht bei dem Herr Doktor Maus.
Vielleicht hat da jemand
sein Neffe oder so,
vielleicht einen kleinen Gag rausgehauen.
Aber ansonsten glaube ich eher nicht.
Abkratzen, glaube ich, kommt auch recht selbst.
Ich möchte, dass du auf meiner Beerdigung
das Wort Mausetot.
So was darfst du nicht sagen, wirklich, so was darfst du nicht sagen,
weil du kannst jeden Tag sterben, du führst ein extrem gefährliches Leben, Stefan, du hast dich letzte Woche mit zwei Jugendlichen angelegt, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, du führst ein extrem gefährliches Leben, Stefan, du hast dich letzte Woche mit zwei Jugendlichen angelegt, das hätte ganz anders ausgehen können, die hätten nicht, wenn die alle ihre vier Hände gemeinsam genommen hätten, hätten die ihre vier Hände um deine Kehle herum bekommen. Ich glaube, ihr mit ihren kleinen jugendlichen Händchen, ich meine einen massiven, ja doch auch sehr stark trainierten Hals. Doch, ich glaube, wenn die alle vier Hände benutzen, hätten die es geschafft. Und dann wäre es aber ganz schnell der Gar ausgegangen. Ja, da wäre mir sowieso ausgegangen. Der Gar. Der Gar. G-A, ne, oder? Der Gar. Nee, Gar aus. Nee, G-A. Wäre mir Gar aus. G-A, Lehrzeichen aus. Und sowas darfst du aber echt nicht sagen, weil am Ende stirbst du tatsächlich
in einem ganz schwerwiegenden
Rolltreppenunfall.
Ganz unangenehm.
Und dann muss jemand
wirklich auf deiner Beerdigung Mausetod sagen.
Auch ein ganz toller Gag vom unvergessener Mitch Hedberg,
der auch noch lebt, ne?
Also nebenbei.
Das Rolltreppen,
die können nie ganz kaputt gehen. Sie werden höchstens zu Treppen. Sorry for the convenience, the elevator is now a stair. Ja, das stimmt schon. Sehr gut. Wohingegen normale Treppen, wenig Fallhöhe, da kann weder nach oben unten, in beide Richtungen.
Ich habe noch nie eine kaputte Treppe gesehen, wo man wirklich sagt, stopp, doch, tatsächlich doch, ja, doch, eine kaputte Treppe, ja, wie, wenn da Stufen abgebrochen sind zum Beispiel, wie geht das denn, zum Beispiel von alten, zum Beispiel Mayas, bei der, bei der Pyramide der Maya, da hast du jetzt die brillante Antwort, da hast du jetzt die Antwort, hä, das kann man nicht in diesem Tonfall sagen, da hast du jetzt die brillante Antwort. Bin ich hochge... Hä? Das kann man nicht in diesem Tonfall sagen. Doch. Da hast du jetzt die brillante Antwort. Ja, doch du einmal in Maya gewesen. Du wartest doch den ganzen Tag nur darauf zu erwähnen, dass du mal bei den Mayas warst. Bei den Maya konnte man nicht jeden Weg hochgehen, weil die Treppen runtergebröselt sind. Aber auch hier und da sind die manchmal slippery, dann werden die gesperrt. Wobei, wenn die Treppe kaputt genug ist, wird es zur Rampe.
Wird es zur Rampe?
Ja.
Wird es zu einer steilen Rampe.
Ideal?
Ideal.
Oder nicht, je nachdem.
Und jetzt zeigt mir erstmal eine kaputte Rampe.
Und dann schauen wir mal wirklich weiter.
Das hast du nämlich nicht gesehen bei deinen Neu-Mexiko-Mexiko-Meyer-Leuten.
Nee, nur Mexiko.
Ich war im Alt-Mexiko.
Gibt es Alt-Mexiko, Mexiko und Neu-Mexiko? Gibt's New York und Ost-York? Brand New York? Brand New York. Oh, können wir Brand New York rinden? Klar, klar. Klar, klar, in Köln? Ja, klar, klar. Aber auf dem Mond oder so gibt's ja nicht Brand Brand New York. Brand New York. Brand New York? Ich weiß es nicht. Moon. Moon York? Ich habe heute eine stelle These aufgestellt, weil heute hat jemand zu mir gesagt, wir haben so über gerade die Zeit gesprochen und dann geht man zu Restaurants und dann kriegt man da irgendwie Takeaway-Essen und dann gibt es Schlangen mittags und das ist alles ein bisschen wie Krieg wirkt das manchmal. und ja takeaway essen das ist wirklich krieg. Da raut Opa noch mal auf. So war es damals, als die Bomben kamen. Da mussten wir immer Takeaway essen. Oh, jetzt müssen wir Takeaway bestellen. Oh, mit dieser kleinen Plastikkabel. Nein, aber du weißt was, meine ich. Das ist schon so eine komische... Ich weiss, was du meinst. Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen kleinen Ulk. Ach, ein bisschen Ulk gemacht, ne? Ja, ja, ist mir aufgefallen. Aber ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen so eine andersartige Situation. Und wie würde aber dann eigentlich ein Krieg aussehen heutzutage? Wie würde der Dritte Weltkrieg heutzutage aussehen? These, ich glaube, weil wirtschaftlich wäre der Schaden ja so groß, es geht ja nicht mehr um so Kriege, also ich glaube, Konflikte heutzutage, ich meine jetzt eben nicht Kriege und Konflikte, die jetzt schon, mein Gott, es ist vor allem, nee, weil ich weiche schon, ich bin schon mitten auf dem Minenfeld, ich bin schon mitten auf dem Minenfeld und ich muss gucken, dass ich mich hier langsam bewege, von Punkt zu Punkt, von Wort zu Wort. Verbunden in Augen. Ich habe also Augen verbunden, Ohren zu. Auf Skischuss den Hang runter. Und man hat mir so große Schuhe angezogen, damit ich eher auf Minen trete. Also, um es kurz zu machen, ich meine nicht die Konflikte, die es gerade gibt, zum Beispiel Gaza. Also, diese Konflikte, weil ich Israel mal ausgezuklammert. Aber ich glaube, es kommt nicht mehr zu grossen Weltkriegen, wie wir sie kennen, weil die Konflikte heutzutage globally zu komplex sind. Da geht es jetzt um wirtschaftliche Vorteile, sowas. Aber es geht nicht um so Billow-Konflikte wie damals, so, ja, wir wollen mehr Ländereien haben, wir wollen Polen, wir wollen Polen. Um sowas geht es nicht mehr. Da sind die Konflikte einigermaßen geklärt. Jetzt Krim und ich weiß. Ja, aber jetzt lass uns Afghanistan mal kurz zur Seite schieben. Zur Seite schieben. Lass uns mal kurz den Schreibtisch leermachen, wir haben alles zur Seite gerade. Auch mal Köpfe leermachen kurz. Generell, gute Idee. Und um uns auf das Wesentliche zu konzentrieren. Belarus ausgeklammert. Kurz mal Kongo zur Seite geschoben. Kurz den Themenflug gemacht. Mal ganz kurz alles zur Seite. Das machen wir später. Das machen wir später. Das kommt dann später wieder in die Addition dazu. Aber glaubst
du, dass es noch so
dusselig rumgeschossen wird?
Nee, glaube ich
aber nicht. Aber das ist auch keine steile
These, dass man seit der
Atombombe sagt, es gibt wahrscheinlich keinen grossen Krieg
mehr, sonst gibt es die Erde nicht mehr.
Das ist, glaube ich, keine so steile These.
Aber ich glaube, es kann auf jeden Fall was dran sein.
Es sei denn, man holt natürlich richtig aus. und es kann natürlich auch in die andere Richtung gehen. Kann natürlich auch passieren. Ich glaube, der Dritte Weltkrieg findet komplett im Internet statt. Tolle, ein Trollkrieg. Ein Trollkrieg, ein reiner Cyberkrieg, durch irgendwelche so Deepfake-Videos werden. Ich glaube, der Dritte Weltkrieg wird ausgetragen in der Kommentarspalte von OJ Simpson Tweets.
Das glaube ich.
Ja.
Und vielleicht korrigiere mich auch keine steile These.
Steile These, der Dritte Weltkrieg läuft bereits.
So, und jetzt, nee, jetzt komm.
Ach.
Ja, ich bin auch ein Provokateur.
Ich bin auch ein Provokateur.
Weißt du, so wie du gerade da sitzt, mit deiner Jogginghose, deinen lustigen Vans, die du schon achtmal anhattest, dann dein ... Uh, achtmal. Schwarz feiert. Und dann mit deinem lustigen Hoodie, ausgeblichem Hoodie. Weißt du, wenn du das sagst, ist es irgendwie auch, ist der dritte, wirklich läuft bereits, irgendwie charmant und süss. Ja, niedlich. Ja, niedlich. Aber wenn du es jetzt mit so einem Weinglas und so einem Schal umgehangen, abends bei mir am Esstisch sagen würdest,
der dritte Weltkrieg läuft bereits.
Ja, es kann sein.
Unsympathisch.
Zum Glück haben wir jetzt den Begriff Weltkrieg.
Jetzt kann man es einordnen, so der dritte Teil.
Du hast es schon mal gecheckt. So der dritte Teil, aber wahrscheinlich gibt es irgendwie die Plotlines ein bisschen weirder. Wahrscheinlich sind die Deutschen höchstwahrscheinlich involviert, gehen wir mal einfach mal aus. So wie wir das Franchise kennen, wird diese Money Machine wahrscheinlich nicht so sehr geändert werden. Und ehrlich gesagt, alle wären auch ein bisschen enttäuscht, wenn es nicht so wäre. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Vor allem, das wäre der schlechteste Twist, der dritte Weltkrieg geht los und die Deutschen sind nicht dabei und alle sagen, come on, den Twist kannst du doch. Und dann Akt zwei, die Deutschen kommen rein, alle ja. Wir waren's doch, wir waren's doch. Schön auf der Kanone vom Panzer rein. Auf dem Ich-sitz-Auffahr-Drohne, die wird ferngestört. Ich sitze drauf. Ich sitze am Laptop.
Drones HD.
Drones HD?
Wow.
Drones HD finde ich aber gut.
Aber kritisch, durchaus kritisch.
Ist eine Predator-Drone?
Drones HD ready.
Drones 4 zu 3.
Drones HD DVD.
Drones V-Eis 4 zu 3.
Ja. Drones 4 zu 3. Ja.
Drones 4 zu 3, ja.
So ein Antikriegs-Animationsfilm, der viermal falsch abgebogen ist in der Pre-Production.
Und am Ende so eine
MP4 in 4 zu 3
Format. Der nur auf USB-Sticks verteilt
wird, nur auf dem Flugzeug
geworfen wird. Ja, aus Drohnen. Ja, okay. Wir haben gesagt, wir wollen ihn ausklammern. Okay, ausgeklammert. Immer noch ausgeklammert. Ausgeklammert. Ausgeklammert. Hängt in so einem Netz unter der Decke. Machbar nicht mehr, ne, Klammern mit Songs, Songtiteln, haben keine Klammern mehr. Finde ich gut. Also das ist sowas so wie dann The Oolala Song oder sowas. Der Pinnacolala Song. Ja genau, stimmt. Macht man selten. Macht man nicht mehr. Der Alalalalong Song. Ist auch so, es gibt so viele vieles Alben, wo man sich denkt, ja das war wahrscheinlich eine lustige Idee, aber es ist einfach nervig, wenn die Titel keine richtigen Namen haben. Zum Beispiel es gibt ein, wir kommen immer
auf die gleichen drei Themen zurück, aber es gibt ein Dimitri
Martin-Album, wo halt
die Titel immer nur heißen. Ich war so froh, dass ich
Bruder liebe. Ich weiß, wo die
Titel nur heißen Jokes,
Some More Jokes, Even More Jokes.
So was. Such mal einen Witz daraus. Ja, such mal
irgendwie den Gag, den du geklaut hast,
den du klauen wolltest. Überprüf mal,
ob der nicht von Dimitri Martin ist, wenn du das nicht suchen kannst. Oh, Joke Sex war's. Er ist problematisch. Deswegen benennt eure Dinge richtig Benennungen. Ich sage euch, gerade im Dritten Weltkrieg, in dem wir uns hier gerade befinden, ist es wichtig, weil das Internet ist ja auch, also wir müssen gucken, wo landen unsere Dinge. Wir haben so viele Fotos, alles ist so gut dokumentiert, überall sind Daten, Daten, Daten, Daten, deswegen ist Benennungen so wichtig. Ja. Ja. Wer soll die Daten alle sichten? Genau. Ist deine Frage, glaube ich. Ist meine Frage, aber für dich, also ich stelle die auch dir, weil du bist nicht gut im Benennen, das weiss ich ja selbst, du benennst nicht gut. Aha. Das weiss ich dir nicht. Geht ja mal näher drauf ein, das würde mich jetzt wirklich interessieren, weil das ist eine meiner Marke. Dein Laptop ist so eine Messie-Wohnung, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich finde, man muss auch mal seinen Laptop ein bisschen aufräumen, ab und zu. So, wenn man mal seine Wohnung aufräumt, alle, weil du da gesellschaftlich... Das ist unhöflich, wenn man jemanden ein Video zeigt auf einem Laptop, der nicht aufgeräumt ist, ist es unhöflich. Nee, aber du kriegst ja gesellschaftlichen Druck, wenn deine Wohnung nicht aufgeräumt ist.
Richtig, ja.
So, aber dein Laptop benutzt ja nur du. Das ist dein kleines Zimmer, wo niemand reingeht.
Ja.
Und nur deswegen ist ja kein Freifahrtschein, dass du da alles offen rumliegen lässt auf dem Schreibtisch.
Ja, okay.
Du lässt ja deine ganzen TXT-Dateien auf dem Schreibtisch liegen.
Alles liegt quer rum.
Ja, liegt quer rum.
Da liegt ein Bild, da liegt eine Rechnung, da liegt eine PDF, da liegt ganz viel TXT-Datei. Oh, Desktop, The Movie? So ein kleines Männchen ist unterwegs. Hier, dieser AOL-Typ. Karl Klammer. Nee, der Messenger-Typ. Tom von MySpace. Mit so einem Renner. Rennenden. Wer rennt. Das Icon von irgendeinem Messenger-Dienst. ISN, IBM Messenger? MSN. MSN, MSN, nee. Nee, weiß ich doch nicht. Keine Ahnung. Es gibt irgendeinen Messenger, wo so jemand läuft. Und der ist dann der Protagonist. Der ist dann der Protagonist? Und der ist auf dem Desktop unterwegs. Ja, und dann kommt der Cursor und dann will er nicht angeklickt werden und der Cursor kommt von oben. Und der will eigentlich nur mal auf diese Insel, die das Hintergrundbild ist. Stimmt, der will da mal hin. Der will da mal hin. Und dann kann er aber nicht hin, weil er in der analogen Welt nicht funktioniert. Und dann gibt es so einen riesen Fiesseil. Er muss erst einen Sip, um in die echte Welt zu kommen. Da wird er nicht entpackt. Und es ist nicht der beste Spiel.
Und dann bringt er sich um.
Ein ehrlicher Pitch.
Wir haben massive dritte Aktprobleme.
Und ehrlich gesagt.
Er zieht sich selbst in den Papierkorb und stirbt.
Genau.
Aber dann kommt raus, da war seine Freunde, die er kennenlernt, auf dem Weg, die ICQ-Blume,
dieser MSN-Runner, ach nee, das ist er ja, Karl Klammer, die er kennenlernt auf dem Weg, die ICQ-Blume, dieser MSN-Runner,
ach nee, das ist er ja, Karl Klammer,
Tom von MySpace, diese ganzen Leute, die man alle kennt,
die mir alle nichts sagen,
aber alle lachen immer, wenn ich
Tom von MySpace sage, and that is
what it's all about. Und deswegen
diese ganzen Leute, die wir im ersten Akt kennengelernt
haben, die retten ihn dann aus dem
Papierkorb, weil im Papierkorb
ist man ja erst gelöscht, wenn man auch noch den Papierkorb löscht. Yes! Und dann heißt das, das ist dann der dritte Akt. Am Ende, die er dann alle kennengelernt hat, auch teilweise sich verfeindet hat, mit denen er befreundet, große Finale, am Ende Feuerwerk. Am Ende Feuerwerk, wenn einem gar nichts einfällt, Feuerwerk einfach. Aber so ein GIF, so ein Drei-Phasen-Animations-GIF von einem Feuerwerk. Drei Bilder pro Minute GIF. Das ist die letzten 20 Minuten. Zum Thema Objects für Idee haben wir auch massive Kritik kassiert. Also da haben wir richtig kassiert. Wir haben kassiert? Da wurden wir richtig bedient, glaube ich. Ich bin bedient. Also ich bin definitiv bedient. Und zwar wurden wir gescholten zum Thema der kleine Toaster. Es gibt bereits einen Film, der kleine Toaster, über Bügeleisen. Die Marketingstrategie hat sich nicht ganz ausgezahlt. Und er gibt es schon, also unsere Idee, wie immer. Wie, was gibt's jetzt? Es gibt den kleinen Toaster, Film über den Toaster. Wir hatten noch Powerbank. Wir hatten Powerbank, aber wie gesagt, die Idee mit Objects gibt's schon, ich bin auch, wir wurden da zu Unrecht bedient. Sausage Party gab's ja auch. Ja. Mit Seth Rogen, da waren auch, ist dringend genommen, auch Objects. Also, reden dann nur Würste, nee. Nee, da reden nur Essen. Da redet Essen Food, ist eigentlich Food 4D. Foods 4D, ja, warum benennen die die immer falsch? Da sind wir wieder bei falschem Benennen. So, wie werden wir beim Thema Benennen? Benennen eure Filme vernünftig? Nee, das meine ich aber auch ganz ehrlich, wo wir auch zum Anfang der Folge wieder zurückkommen, ist es lächerlich gut geframed, diese Folge, aber manchmal fällt mir der Name nicht ein, Donald Raper zum Beispiel. Wenn das nicht so eine lächerliche 0815-Alliteration wäre, sondern der einen vernünftigen Namen hätte, könnte ich mir den Effekt merken. Peter Krakowski. Den kann ich mir merken. Benennt alle Leute richtig. Benennt Figuren richtig, benennt Serien richtig, benennt... Bitte Leute, reisst euch zusammen, benennt Sachen richtig. Ja, wenn wir richtig Sachen benennen, dann kommen wir alle als Gesellschaft weiter. Gebt vor allem, wenn ihr was erfindet irgendwie, dann so beim Bäcker oder so, so neue Brötchen, gebt denen vernünftige Namen. Oh Gott, das ist mir so unangenehm. Gebt denen vernünftige Namen, gebt denen nicht irgendeinen Schwachsinnsnamen, sondern ich habe heute auch, oh Gott, ich dachte mir vor allem, es gibt so dieses eine Brot, das heisst Rustica.
Das ist das Schlimmste, was man will. Da habe ich wirklich überlegt, ich hätte gerne zwei Rusticae, ich kann das jetzt nicht, ich kann das jetzt nicht in Lateinpluch halt sagen, Salve Magister, due Rusticae. Rüstige, por favor.
Aber voll.
Man sieht auch immer dann so Knusperstängli, Knüsperchen, ein Schlemmerchen, Züngli, immer so dieses Verniedlichungsscheisse. Ganz, ganz schrecklich. Ich kann mir, will ich, bei mir ist ja bei Franzbrötchen schon auch vorbei. Ja, das finde ich schon länger nicht. Zuckerbrot. Zuckerbrot, das ist es es. Zucker mit Zimtbrot, das da. Zimtzuckerbrot. Zimtzuckerzwirbel, sowas. Wenn es dann komplett lächerlich ist. Aber im Grunde ist es ja auch immer nur hier das da. Nee, das da. Manchmal habe ich auch Angst, mich zu versprechen bei manchen. Ich habe mich schon so oft bei dem Wort Kartoffelbrot oder Kartoffelkrustel, glaube ich gerade, versprochen, dass ich es nicht mehr bestelle.
Ich glaube aber, wenn man tatsächlich... Hier in Köln, weil es ist Zeit für Brot, keine mehr Kartoffelkrustel. Ich verspreche mir dabei und deswegen bestelle ich es nicht mehr. Es schmeckt mir so gut, aber ich vertraue mich nicht. Das wäre was anderes. Nee, aber dann bitte und dann hat man die Maske auf und dann versteht man sich nicht. Scheiße. Ich glaube aber, wenn man mal wirklich bei so einer Bäckerei wirklich richtig bestellen würde,
würde das auch auffallen.
Ich hätte gerne drei
Fit Vital-Knäcker und
zwei
Premium Lifestyle-Weckerl
und wirklich alles richtig sagen, da würde ich auch
sagen, ja, jetzt komm, willst du mich verraten?
Drei Weltmeisterbrötchen und bitte einmal
die Knusperstange.
Weltmeisterbrötchen. Perfekte Name. Da bin ich nicht Wenn ich das nicht mehr so viel, was ich nicht mehr so viel, was ich nicht mehr so viel, was ich nicht mehr als Kind, wo ich nicht genommen wurde. Antenne-Una-Brötchen, weil da hat die Hörerschaft und Antenne-Una hat wohl beschlossen, aus welchem Teich und welche Karna und so das haben soll. Deswegen gibt es jetzt Antenne-Una-Brötchen. Aber würde ich auch nicht bestellen, weil ich bin ja auch albern. Ich kam mir auch bescheuert vor, weil es gab mal bei McDonalds diese Aktion, dass man seinen eigenen Burger designen konnte und dann konnten Leute online abstimmen, welcher dann tatsächlich produziert und verkauft wird.
Und da hat gewonnen Steve Vino. Kennen vielleicht manche von euch aus der WoW-Szene, der hat bei Elemania und so mitgemacht und das kreiert, glaube ich. Und erkennt man vielleicht, wenn man aus diesem Kosmos kommt. Und der hat auch gewonnen, weil der einfach eine große Online-Follower-Schaft hat. Und dann haben alle für den Just-Stevenio-Burger abgestimmt. Und dann bin ich extra zum McDonalds gegangen, diese Aktion hat auf ganzer Linie funktioniert und musste wirklich dann zweimal nochmal so im Kreis raus und wieder reinlaufen, einfach mit genug Selbstbewusstsein zu sagen, ich hätte gerne den Just-The-Vinio-Burger einfach. Das war wirklich so mit viel Anlauf und die Leute guckten mich auch so an, so ach so, ja, ja, okay, ganz, ganz furchtbar. Da auch irgendwie klar, ich meine, er heisst Justio, so, aber da hättest du einfach irgendwie schön den Gurkenburger nennen können, damit das Leute vernünftig bestehen. Unangenehm, ey. Nee, aber bei sowas bin ich immer noch nicht gut. Nee. Ich kann auch nicht so gut bestellen und so. Ich hab da immer noch Probleme mit. Wann hört das auf, wann hört das auf? Ich kann dann gut bestellen, wenn ich schon routiniert habe, so bei Subway oder so, da wirklich dann komplett runterrattern und so und auch wirklich so McDonalds oder so, dass da keine Nachfrage mehr kommt und wirklich schon alles so mitnehmen, mit Ketchup, mit dem, mit dem, mit dem, dann ist alles klar, aber so bei anderen Situationen, gerade so mit viel zeigen und lesen, schwierig. Ich frage mich auch häufig, bestelle ich jetzt das, was ich gerade wirklich will oder weil ich es schon mal bestellt habe und es hat schon mal keine Probleme vor. Weil sowas wie bei Subway, so weiß ich, was ich da immer bestellt habe und es hat immer funktioniert. Es kam nie Gegenfragen, es kam nie ein, ja, aber jetzt wollen Sie das so und so, sondern das ging immer so einfach durch. Bestelle ich es deswegen oder weil ich das wirklich für das beste Sandwich halte? Am Grunde sollte man nicht fragen, was ist das Beste, was Sie haben, sondern was ist am einfachsten zu bestellen. Was ist am einfachsten zu bestellen, wo kann man am wenigsten Rückfragen, was haben Sie gerade da, wo kommt nicht noch eine Frage, ob ich es aufwärmen soll, weil ich entscheide mich auch falsch, weil man sich unter Druck aufwärmen oder nicht. Nein, ihr könnt euch mit Sandwiches aus, ihr solltet es entscheiden. Idee, du hast bei Subway nicht nur die normalen Bestellvorgänge, sondern du hast auch einfach einen Knopf, einen grünen Knopf. Ein Buzzer. Einfach einen Buzzer. Warum grün? Weil Subway grüne Farbe hat. Und wenn du hingehst und einfach dir überlegst, was soll ich mit der ersten Stelle, du drückst einfach nur auf diesen grünen Knopf. Und bezahlst dann 1.800 Euro im Dreck-Standwich. Und kriegst dann einfach halt irgendwas, das Standard-Standwich. Aber da steht auch, da steht ein Preis drauf. Auf dem grünen, ja, der ist vielleicht so ein bisschen abgewetzt. Der ist ganz klein auch. Ja, vielleicht kann man neben dem Knopf noch ein Schild aufstellen oder so, dass das auf dem Schild der Preis steht. You don't have to speak, just press the button button. Genau. You don't have to order, it's just the button, press the button button. Und auf dem Button steht press this button. So. It's the press this button. Down. Press this button down. Push it down. Ja, sehr, sehr leicht auf die Lippen war das. Und dann geht er nicht, hat er aber schon aber schon bezahlt, irgendwie waren die Karte, und dann muss man zur Kasse gehen und sagen, ich habe gerade den Press-this-down-button-button gedrückt, wollte eigentlich und hat sich nicht funktioniert. Und dann wird dir einfach zufällig irgendein Sandwich generiert. Ja, es wird irgendein Sandwich generiert, was hoffentlich keine Rückfragen auslöst.
Deswegen, ja, wir haben letzte Woche, kam sehr, sehr gut an der Community zum Thema Eisbär-Emoji. Die Leute haben sich gefreut, benutzen das Emoji schon nicht genug manchmal noch, aber benutzen es. Meine Idee wäre ja, mal weg von dummen Ideen hin zu guten Ideen, nicht irgendwie jetzt ein neues Emoji. Emoji, ja, jetzt kommt, was kommt der Panda-Bär, der Koala-Bär, der Leguan-Bär, ein Pinker-Bär. So, nee, neuer Button, random emoji. Aber liegt nicht... Was ist das Lachen der Leute über den Gag?
Es ist so lustig, wenn man in ... Habe ich schon mal erzählt.
Aber wenn man in Filmen oder Serien Stille erzählen will, am besten macht man das mit Lärm.
Also man zum Beispiel hinten Autobahn rein oder einen Flieger startet oder die Lüftung eine Uhr, Klassiker, ist stiller als stille. Ja, finde ich albern. Ja, aber nee, ich habe auch die... Weil vielleicht kommt dann einfach der normale oder irgendwann ein Herz und dann denkt man so, dass man nachher eine weirden... Naja, du kannst da schon so Häkchen setzen. Beziehungen Beziehung, die man nicht einfüllt. Keine Herzen, keine Flaggen, keine ungewollten Liebschaften. Du musst Häkchen setzen, bei allen Emojis. Du kannst in die Einstellungen, Einstellungen, allgemein Kommunikation, Auberginen raus, dieser Wasserspritz Emoji raus. Vor allem nicht in Kombination. Vor allem auf der Einfall in Kombination. Das kannst du alles raushaken und dann Schwangerschafts-Emoji raus. Vor allem nicht in Kombination. Vor allem auf gar keinen Fall in Kombination.
Das kannst du alles raushaken
und dann... Schwangerschafts-Emoji raus.
Es gibt ein Schwangerschafts-Emoji?
Wenn nicht, wäre das mein...
Gut? So.
Aber wie könnte das aussehen?
Eine Frau mit
zwei Händen daneben im runden Bauch.
Und dann so ein Mann, der so hört.
Und dann aber auch so ein Querschnitt durch die Frau. Das Kind hört auch. Das Kind hört auch nach draußen. Aber auch so mit so genervten Augen. Hä, was sagst du? Was? Ich verstehe kein Wort. Ich verstehe nichts. Das Herz pocht laut direkt neben meinem Ohr. Vielleicht können Kinder im Bauch schon sprechen. Hat das mal jemand überprüft, hat jemand mal so ein Mikro, so ein kleines... Was? Ich habe Wasser im Mund. Verrückt, ne? Fruchtwasser im Mund. Dass die Wasser im Mund haben, die ganzen Tage. Fische auch die ganze Zeit. Aber der Nabel...
Fische haben Salzwasser in den Augen, die ganze Zeit.
Es ist im Nabel angeschlossen.
Das heißt, so ein Embryo atmet nicht, sondern atmet es dann so mit dem Bauch?
Ich verstehe es nicht. Aber das Embryo hat die Bauchnabelkabel. Ich verstehe diese Scheiße. Ich glaube, als ich als Embryo war, dachte ich, was ist das für eine Scheiße, wie soll das für eine Dreckscheiße. Schwachsinn einfach, nur gemotzt neun Monate lang. Unsinn und Dreck. Und dann wird auch getreten, die wollen raus, die haben keinen Bock mehr. Raus hier, das ist für eine Scheiße? Ich weiß nicht, wie ich atme, ich kann nicht sprechen, Wasser im Mund. Es ist stockdunkel. Es ist stockduster. Nicht mal so ein kleines Leselämpchen oder so was. Nee, stockduster. Aber angenommen, kann man da nicht auch so ein bisschen Pranks machen? Angenommen, du bringst da so ein kleines Lämpchen rein, hat das Kind dann schon früher Augen? Oder ist das so ein kleines Büchlein? Oder wird es blind. Oder wird es blind. Oder erklärbar so Harry Potter und die Gefährten, ganz klein. Harry Potter und die Gefährten. Du hast meinen Zauberstab und meinen Elderstab und meinen Tarnumhang. Du warst gar nicht eingeladen zur Versammlung, Ron. Es führen viele Wege nach ... Man spaziert nicht einfach nach Askerbahn. Das müssen wir eigentlich mal machen. Antenne, Auenland, Askerbahn. Antenne? Antenne, Askerland. Irgendwie sowas. Antenne, Askerland. Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee. Man, one does not simply walk to Askerbahn. Toll. Wenn zwei Franchises nicht mehr so gut funktionieren, einfach kombinieren. Crossover, fucking crossover, man. Gibt's viel zu selten. Oder zu häufig, da bin ich ganz offen. Eins von beiden... Sucht euch eure Meinung aus. Das ist nämlich jetzt der neue Stefan, da wir kriegen immer gegen mit bei allem. Deswegen so eine Und-Oder-Folge, ihr könnt euch aussuchen. Schreibt gerne in die Kommentare, ob es in euren Augen zu viele oder zu wenige Crossover gibt. Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine ganz fantastische Woche.
Eine ganz fantastische Woche. Kommt gut heim.
Oder ans Ziel, oder macht doch immer, was ihr wollt.
Schlaft gut ein, macht schön auf.
So, eben ab.
Worst World Production.